[Music]
Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn is one of the
most popular Nickelodeon shows and after
three years it's still running strong it
launched acting careers of several
talented kid actors and today we'll
explore them in more detail stay tuned
to see how the show made Lizzie Greene's
dreams come true hey guys check out our
new member of the family toy hub toy hub
is the ultimate place for kids to get
their daily dose of crunchy slime
squishy slime sticky slime play-doh
color learning and so much more we have
lots of fun with the most awesome toys
and amazing stories for kids make sure
to show it to all the kids in your
family and while you're there make sure
to subscribe and hit that like button at
toy hub it's playtime don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
Channel now let's check out the cast of
Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn in real life
Ann Harper you probably know Ann Harper
as the caring mom of the quadruplets who
takes charge and doesn't put up with any
nonsense but just how much do you know
about the actress behind the role her
name is Alison Munn and you wouldn't
believe it when we tell you that she was
in absolutely all of your favorite
sitcom series remember what I like about
you with Amanda Bynes
she was playing Tina Haven who was an
outspoken and straight to-the-point
character she also played Lauren on One
Tree Hill and even played Caroline in
That 70's Show and before you ask no
she's actually not related to the
popular actress Olivia Munn
however Alyson in real life is actually
quite similar to the character she plays
on Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn she's
actually a mom and has two kids we bet
her role as Anne gave her some new
insight into motherhood and confirmed
that quadruplets are a lot of work the
characters really look like one big
happy family
but they actually act that way behind
the scenes too isn't that cute everyone
deserves to have such a caring mother
like Anne Harper but all mothers have a
secret and Anne is no exception
did you know her real name is actually
not Anne it's John tall we wonder how
many other secrets this character is
hiding Tom Harper
Thomas Harper is definitely one of the
most interesting characters on the show
and a typical Nickelodeon dad well he's
a father of four children he seems to
take more interest in his gadgets and
technology while his wife takes care of
the kids he's still affectionate but it
looks like he's interested in other
things
found him sounds a bit unfair doesn't it
Tom even owns a restaurant but it seems
like he's never actually working well
luckily the real-life Tom Harper doesn't
share anything with his character other
than his looks his real name is Brian
Stepanek and he's also been on some of
your favorite shows and you probably
don't even know which did you know he's
the voice of the dad on the loud house
and he even voiced Martin on bolt
alongside Miley Cyrus you might also
know him as the hotel engineer Arwen on
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody
it sounds like Brian is pretty busy
luckily the actor is a bit more
interested in this show than his actual
character you should check out his
Instagram where he sometimes posts
behind the scenes of the show do you
remember this diva these two look like
they definitely get along Brian has
three children and we bet he's not as
uninvolved in their lives as Tom is may
Valentine coming up next is May
Valentine Don's best friend who also
easily gets along with everyone else in
the Harper family she's dating Myles who
also has some real-life secrets May is
portrayed by Kyla drew Simmons who's
acting career is growing bigger by the
minute you might have spotted Kyla in a
Jessie episode called from the White
House to our house where she played
Taylor or perhaps you've seen her in How
I Met Your mother's episode called mom
and dad we're certain Kyla will be
landing more and more roles but we have
to admit that we do love her bubbly
character in Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
we bet you didn't know Kyla actually has
asthma
she needs to carry her inhaler at all
times Kyla is also bilingual she speaks
English and Spanish
she also says she's obsessed with
colleges Stanford and MIT and she was in
10th grade at just 12 years of age
sounds like she's a pretty smart cookie
doesn't it Kyla's personality is
actually a lot similar to Mays and it
seems like everyone loves her she can be
goofy and bubbly but she definitely
seems to take her acting career very
seriously we can't wait to see what's in
store for Kyla next but we have to say
that we also love her on the show Eiffel
next is a popular ballet dancer and a
star of her own reality show called life
of eiffel we loved seeing the
quadruplets sitting in front of TV and
getting excited over eiffel's new show
she appeared in only two episodes but it
made everyone buzz when they saw who was
playing Eiffel the real-life version of
the character goes by the name Maddie
Ziegler and you might know her from the
hit TV show Dance Moms and Sia's music
videos
maddie was named one of the most
influential teens in 2016 and she
definitely left her mark in the dance
world she has almost 10 million
followers on Instagram and just over a
million on Twitter but there's a reason
why Maddie's so popular and so
unbelievably talented this little power
machine trains in a dance studio for 40
hours a week that's a full-time job
she's constantly on the road and she
definitely is one of the most
recognizable teenage celebrities over
the past few years SIA personally cast
Maddie to be in her videos after
watching her dance on Dance Moms she
reached out to her on Twitter and the
rest is history
did you know her actual name wasn't
going to be Maddie her parents named her
Taylor and changed it to Madison just a
few days after she was born we'd love to
see more of Ifill on the show Lily
and then there's eiffel's sister Lily
who also stars on the life of eiffel
reality show
Lily's character also appeared on two
episodes of Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
but the actors who plays her is so
popular those were some of the most
talked-about episodes ever you know her
- it's Mackenzie Ziegler the other half
of the duo that is the Ziegler sisters
she also made a name for herself after
starring in the popular Dance Moms
series and although she was often
overshadowed by her big sister Mackenzie
is also an amazing dancer and on top of
that she's absolutely hilarious if you
saw the show you probably remember her
saying that she doesn't want to go on
Broadway she just wants to stay at home
and eat chips which is absolutely
hilarious just like her sister Mackenzie
is still dancing but she's also
dedicating a lot of her time to her
music career in 2017 she released songs
called teamwork and monsters and earlier
in the year she collaborated with Johnny
Orlando on day and night which got an
impressive 17 million views on YouTube
it seems like the Sigler sisters aren't
stopping anytime soon and we can't wait
to see more of their work however we do
also hope that Mackenzie returns to her
role of Lily on Nicky Ricky Dicky and
Dawn again Josie Josie only appeared on
the first season of the show
but fans miss seeing her as she was one
of the friendliest and bubbliest
characters she was also the kid's
babysitter and we guessed that as time
went on and the kids got older Josie's
character didn't make much sense to be
there however Gabrielle Elise the
actress that plays Jody does seem to be
pretty busy
you probably recognize her from her
cameos on shows like Liv and Maddie
Austin & Ally a few years ago in 2017
Gabrielle also had just a minor role in
modern family however it looks like
she's also a part of some bigger shows
and movies of course nothing compares to
Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn and we'd
really love to see her return for the
future seasons here's a little inside
scoop he managed to find from the first
season on the show apparently the kids
gave Gabrielle just as much trouble off
camera as they did on camera they made
fun of her after she had a crush on one
of the cute behind the scenes counter
boys she joked that one day she'll find
a man of her dreams and it'll get ruined
by the mischievous younger cast
come on Nickelodeon let's bring Josie
back on the show Nikki let's take a
moment to talk about the youngest and
arguably the cutest of the quadruplets
Nikki is definitely the quietest and
most well-mannered out of the four but
of course when you have three other
siblings it's really hard to stay away
from trouble instead of causing havoc on
the show Nikki brings amazing cookies
which quite frankly is a lot better he's
portrayed by Aidan Gallagher who's also
just starting his acting career did you
know he's had a small cameo on Modern
Family nikki is as cute as a button but
so is Aiden did you know he also plays
guitar and he's such a good swimmer he
managed to save someone from drowning he
also revealed that his favorite Nicky
Ricky Dicky and Dawn episode is called
the quadfather from the first season it
definitely looks like aiden is justice
chill and well-mannered as his character
on the show he even said several kids
are behind-the-scenes pranksters but of
course Aiden was not a part of it if
you're not convinced that Aiden really
is a sweet soul
here's something that will make your
heart feel all fuzzy when asked what is
the best holiday present he ever
received
Aiden replied saying it's probably
getting time with his family
see his character is exactly like Nikki
and we bet he can cook too Dicky Dicky
is the second youngest of the Harper
quad clan but probably the one who
manages to get himself in the most
shenanigans he categorizes himself as
the cool one of the group well he's
definitely the one that really cares
about his appearance and of course the
opposite gender Dicky always manages to
get himself in trouble and drag the
other three along for the ride he can
sometimes be seen as arrogant especially
since he doesn't have any other
interests or a hobby but let's not hold
that against him and talk about the
actor who portrays him instead
his name is mace Coronel who's also
known as richer
in Santa hunters and Louie in shoelace
although he plays an arrogant character
mace is a slightly more humble and
down-to-earth type of person if you're
looking to see more of mace we recommend
watching his youtube channel where he
has over 100,000 subscribers may said
he'd love to see the show pair up with
the thundermans especially since Nicky
Ricky Dicky and Dawn is one of the few
shows where characters don't have actual
superpowers we'd love to see that
crossover happen but we absolutely can't
wait to see more of mace in the upcoming
episodes mace also has an important
message to share with all his fans he
says to be happy love yourself and love
everyone around you Ricky let's move on
to the second oldest and the one that
always fights for the leader position of
the group if you have a lot of siblings
you know what it's like
Ricky is smart and enjoys reading books
but unlike his younger siblings he's not
afraid of getting in trouble after all
what's life without a bit of fun right
he's played by Casey Simpson who's most
known for his role in escape from mr.
lemon cello's library did you know he's
also listed as an additional voice in
Despicable Me 2 Casey is one of the
cutest child actors in real life he's
also very outspoken and super fun did
you know that Casey's not a fan of
s'mores he said he just likes to roast
them until they turn black and then just
eat the crackers on their own in one of
the nickelodeon interviews Casey also
mentioned his favorite song is that's
what I like by Bruno Mars and he loves
anything related to the beach and the
ocean we can definitely relate to this
kid and we can't wait to see Ricky in
the future episodes of the show while
we're at it here's a challenge for you
try saying Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
five times fast it's a real tongue
twister but we bet someone like Ricky
could pull this off without a problem
dawn and last but not least it's the
only girl in the clan of quadruplets
dawn Harper is known as the leader of
the group and as the oldest she always
fights with her younger siblings she was
born four seconds before the others and
according to her she's four seconds
older smarter and wiser we have to admit
it looks like it's very hard trying to
be a girl and having some privacy when
you have three other siblings who are
the same age as you but dawn or better
yet Lizzy Green seems to manage it just
like in the show
Lizzy is the oldest in real life and
even though she definitely doesn't have
the same struggles as dawn she did
mention that the cast sometimes does
bicker
the same way as the quadruplets she also
has a YouTube channel where she keeps
more than 150,000 subscribers updated on
her life behind the scenes did you know
that the show was Lizzie's first
introduction to the real acting world
and she didn't even think the show would
be this successful what a dream come
true if your wish is to be an actor
Lizzie is definitely proof that your
career can kick off when you least
expect it - we can't wait to see what
projects Lizzie will have after the show
will be also can't wait for future
seasons of Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn
that's it for checking out the cast of
Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn for more
videos like this one check out ten
Despicable Me characters in real life
see you next time
[Music]